[Music]
the watership down remake has arrived
just in time for Christmas and similar
to the source material there's a lot to
unpack from the newly adapted TV
mini-series throughout this video I'll
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about the four episode
series as well as its ending there will
of course be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want to know anything just yet
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to our story starts at a Warren
inne Sandiford where we join a group of
rabbits yes rabbits I know they look
like hares but it's clear that the BBC
spent more on the cast budget than they
did the animation so look let's just
skip past that anyway after one of the
rabbits named fiber has a premonition
that humans are coming to build a
housing estate on the area they live
they decide to leave this doesn't sit
too well with the elders of the Warren
even though there's a massive sign that
says they're building there so fiber his
brother hazel a larger rabbit named
bigwig and a handful of others decide to
leave in search of a new place to live
eventually they come across a rabbit
named cowslip in the wild who invites
them to join his Warren on the surface
this place looks like a paradise humans
from a neighboring farm bring food to
the rabbits daily and the area is well
sheltered but it's clearly just
something wrong with the place fiber
warns against living there and he's soon
proven right when we discover that
humans are in fact only feeding the
rabbits to harvest them for their meat
and skin it's pretty terrifying and the
rabbits have turned into fearful
creatures almost inventing their own
religion to give reasoning and purpose
to their death living by the mantra a
day less for one means a day more for
everyone else
after bigwig Neely dies after being
trapped in a snare set by a farmer the
herd decides to continue to the down and
they stumble across the farm where we
see some female rabbits trapped in cages
they finally reached the down but
quickly realized that the new home won't
be able to thrive due to there being
more males and female rabbits which are
referred to as those a former survivor
from their previous home named captain
Holly arrives heavily wounded and states
that fiber was indeed right and at the
housing estate pretty much
the majority of the population which
ends part 1 part 2 which is called the
raid no not after the movie though it
probably is a lot more gory involves the
rabbits trying to find goes doze doze in
different area codes you see what I did
there
hazel fiber and bigwig set after the
farm to free the trap rabbits and a bird
with a broken wing crushed lands at the
town eventually they nurse it back to
health and when flying out it notices a
group of rabbits off to the east that
captain Holly a Bluebell and black Brisa
off to find meanwhile at the farm when
trying to free the female rabbits and
they are spotted by a farm cat which
chases them away captain Holly and Co
arrive at the other Warren which is
named F rafin this is a totalitarian
Warren in which stronger rabbits rule
over the weak forcing them to work and
being extremely vicious to those who
refuse the Warren's leader general wound
war is pretty much just negan in a Bugs
Bunny costume and he threatens them
brands them and forces them to work in
the prison this Warren is like George
Orwell's 1984 and the rabbits that live
there have surrendered their freedom in
turn for protection from humans but even
that isn't guaranteed captain Holly
takes the others and decides to make a
break for it and the rabbits end up
almost dying after playing chicken with
a train
hazel decides to return to the farm
under the cover of night but discovers
that the rabbit huts have been moved
inside so he goes into solid snake mode
and breaks in to free them unfortunately
he's discovered after he sets them free
and they encountered the farmers dog
before the farmer chases them shooting
hazel in the process hazel dies for a
moment and is greeted by the black
rabbit which is the personification of
death the black rabbit informs him that
he will be a great leader which shocks
him back to life and ends part 2 episode
3 the escape centers around the rabbits
of the down following 5 is vision of his
brother in order to save him after one
of the rabbits named clover wanders
around in what looks like Silent Hill
for a while she discovers him however
she soon caught by the rabbits from a
free fan and is taken there bigwig
infiltrates their ranks as an officer
and informs the doze that Watership
plans to spring them the rabbits try to
escape for this fails and after
suspicion arises around bigwig he is put
in a position
where he must kill one of the dissenting
dough's to prove his authenticity
bigwig refuses to and instead fights the
other officers springing dose free and
regrouping with the other rabbits
unfortunately them by wound Ward's
forces in the rain so you know it's epic
kiha aka Steven Seagal busts in and
disperses them pretty quickly which buys
the rabbits time to return to escape to
the down where they flourished for a
while until afro fans forces track them
down
they lay siege to water ship and attack
killing several rabbits in the process
man I thought this was meant to be a
kids movie anyway all looks lost until
Professor X with some help from Fiverr
travels to the farm to free the farmers
dog to lead it back to warship in the
meantime a bigwig provides a distraction
and battles wound Ward head to head
hazel arrives with the dog and wound
wart refuses to back down leaping at the
dog stating that he fears a no dog we
never get confirmation of his death in
either movie or the book and in that
some of his followers even believe that
he still exists in the source material
rabbits would tell their kittens that if
they didn't do as they were told he
would come for them so he's pretty much
became the boogeyman of the rabbit world
which is something that I'm sure he
would have always wanted anyway fibre
returns after being saved by a human
girl and the colony thrives once more as
the seasons pass with Mackenzie Crook
doing and I saw a first reference that
fans of the office will love hazel rests
by the river and reflects on everything
that's happened before he's proud that
he and his brother built a new place for
him and his friends and fiber comes to
the river to say goodbye to his brother
after sensing that he will die soon
hazel looks into the water and sees the
reflection of the black rabbit which
comes to greet him and states that she
wants him to join her most privileged
subjects hazel accepts this honor safe
in the knowledge that the rabbits will
live on and he becomes a legend that is
recounted to the children of the down
for generations to come
and a promise from not crying is just
something stuck a math role to me the
main message to take from watership down
is humankind's effects on the
environment there are clear symbols of
how each Warren has been affected in
different ways due to man's damage to
nature Sandiford slowly is polluted and
noah is green
and items like a trash can lid highlight
the opening of garbage into the
environment the area that cows that
lives in seems like a paradise due to
the surroundings but this farmland is
actually cultivated by farmers in all
forms much in the same way that they
plant seeds in order to reap what they
sow they are too fattening of the
rabbits so they can use them for other
means
ephra fan is set in an industrial area
and this too clearly has had an effect
on the wildlife which have regress into
rabbits that live in the darkness and
their personalities have become twisted
because of this it highlights that we
must be mindful of our actions on the
environment as they have dire
consequences that we should perhaps be
more thoughtful towards so what did you
take from watership down did you enjoy
the film and what did you think of the
animation and style comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of this week's other big
Netflix release bird box which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]